sandra republican texas senator ted cruz
joins us now he's a member of the senate
foreign relations committee his father
fled cuba
in the 1950s and he's got an op-ed out
titled cuba libre
in the national review today senator
good to talk to you we heard from jen
saki the press secretary at the briefing
just a short time ago
saying that the cuban people are rising
up against oppression and mismanagement
from the government that the bide
administration
supports their right to protest but as
phil keating was pointing out just a
moment ago
alejandro mayorkas the dhs secretary has
no
interest in entertaining anybody coming
across the florida straits to make an
asylum claim
here's what he said yesterday listen
here
the time is never right to attempt
migration
by sea to those who risk their lives
doing so this risk is not worth taking
allow me to be clear if you take
to the sea you will not come
to the united states now nobody wants to
see a risky mass migration across the
florida states it is
very very dangerous but there seems to
be some contradictory messaging going on
here that on the southern border between
the u.s and mexico democrats are saying
entertain all asylum claims mjorkis is
rejecting that out of hand when it comes
to cubans what do you think
look that's that's exactly right it
seems for joe biden and kamala harris
the only immigrants on the face of the
earth that they don't want to come to
america
are cubans that's the only instance in
which the biden administration
is expressing a resistance to people
coming here illegally
in my home state of texas we have open
borders we have the biden dhs
releasing people hundreds of thousands
of people were also saying i spoke
uh yesterday with with a texas mayor
down on the border who was describing
that they're seeing covet cases
skyrocketing as more and more people are
being released and the bite
administration
is is leaning in even further but when
it comes to cuba
it's not complicated here's what joe
biden needs to say
the communist dictatorship in cuba is
evil
it is oppressive they are murderers they
are torturers
and the people want freedom the american
people
stand with the cuban people and and
unfortunately
the biden administration has been
lukewarm at best
on on that simple and clear messaging so
so do you think that there is a moment
here that if the bible administration of
the u.s were to apply pressure that
something might give in cuba
so i think it's certainly possible we
have seen moments when there's uprisings
you know the green revolution
in iran was an example of the people
rising up and barack obama was president
that and the obama administration did
then what the biden administration is
doing now which is giving lukewarm
support for the protesters you know i'll
tell you john i got i want to read to
you a text that i got from my mother
my mother and our families in
communications with family friends that
are still in cuba
and and here's what what one close
friend of the family said
things are much more serious there than
what is reported on tv
and this friend of the family described
she says she has no food same for almost
everyone
yesterday she had a bowl of thin soup
nothing more
she was asking for help for the first
time no way to get money into cuba banks
are closed
five protesters were killed in santiago
radio stations
are being taken over by protesters
internet shut down
so no further contact available matanzas
which is where my dad was born
is a hot spot for covid and it sounds as
though desperate times are generating
desperate measures this is
an inflection point and america ought to
stand up
and speak boldly on the side of freedom
and against the communist dictatorship
and you know your show mentioned a
minute ago
the the the socialists in congress the
democrats who are unwilling
to condemn the regime the reason is the
cuban government is a socialist
dictatorship and american socialists
don't want to acknowledge
the evil and suffering and oppression
that cuban socialists are imposing on
the people
you know senator you mentioned the
hardships obviously in cuba uh some
texas democrats are suggesting that
they're going through hardship having to
have a salad
while they're here in washington d.c
after fleeing the lone star state
a short time ago kamala harris met with
them and
likened them to that the people who
during the civil rights era were
protesting for the right to vote listen
here
they took bold courageous action
in line with the legacy of everyone from
frederick douglass was over my right
shoulder
when he fought for the right of black
men to vote in america
to the legacy that includes all those
women who marched down pennsylvania
avenue
for women's right to vote to all of
those folks who shed their blood on the
edmund pettus bridge
to make sure that we would in 1965 pass
the voting rights act
she says they took bold courageous
action they got on a couple of private
planes with a case of beer and flew to
washington is that comparable
it's actually pretty ridiculous last i
checked the heroic civil rights
protesters on the edmund pettus bridge
were not in a private chartered jet they
didn't have a case of miller lite next
to them
look these are partisan democrats
playing
a political stunt and and they're
desperate for media attention they're
getting it
the biden administration wants to play
politics and so they're doing that
but but this is going to fail they're
going to eventually have to come home
and when they come home the governor has
rightly said
he will continue to call special
sessions uh until
texas passes voter integrity law to
protect the integrity of elections and
and if these house democrats continue
pulling this stunt
they're going to be arrested and the
texas constitution gives ample authority
to arrest legislators who are trying to
shut down the operation of government
and to forcibly make them present on the
house floor
so that the wheels of government can
continue to turn so when their stunt is
over
the legislature will do its job i need a
quick answer we just got
some seconds left here senator but all
of this is wrapped around the for the
people act
house resolution one senate bill one
there is a suggestion that the democrats
might try to go for a carve out
in the filibuster to try to get this
passed what will senate republicans do
to try to
forestall look i hope they don't do that
if they end the filibuster the damage to
the country is catastrophic this bill
s1 many of us are calling it the corrupt
politicians act
it would strike down voter id laws
across the country it would strike down
prohibitions on ballot harvesting
it would automatically register
potentially millions of illegal
immigrants
it would allow felons to vote
to keep democrats in power the next
hundred years and it is a corrupt
power grab that thankfully i don't think
is going to pass
unless the democrats managed to end the
filibuster right well
uh jan saki indicating a little while
ago that there's not the votes to do
that at least on a permanent basis we'll
see if they can do it on a carver basis
uh senator ted cruz of texas always good
to spend time with you thanks for
joining us today good to be with you
thanks sandra